This little thing is the secret.
You see,
it's got this little sensor right here and this little green light.
And you stand in front of it
and it even the camera adjusts to your height so you can adjust it.
This thing adjusts to your camera.
Just little springs that you open.
It also rotates this way and it also bends like this way.
I mean almost all, all the way around
whatever you need to do. And it's got a really sturdy little base.
And then you can even take this part off
and attach this to a different tripod
so it can be even a better height.
But that just comes tabletop ready.
Sometimes I like to be over here
and sometimes I like to hang out over here.
And if you're alone at home
and you need someone to help you film some shit
and you need help, so if you have like a high thing you can set it on,
like, I had it on my bookcase,
this thing will upgrade your content creation.
Just saying. It does help you film shit when you wanna kinda like
walk around and move and like
make it look cool and shit.
So link on the TikTok shop right now
and there's a ton of sales cause of back to school,
so grab one while you can.